guys
there is no bigger flex in cs go than
getting an ace
look the enemy team can have the biggest
brains they can have the
thickest strap book they can hit all the
innovative made stacks or timing pushes
they want and they can have the
crispiest comms
in the history of the game and none of
that is going to matter
if you can click on five heads in a row
first
here are the top 10 craziest most
legendary
most memorable cs go aces of all time
starting us off is the one and only
techmeister pulling off an
absolute classic of an ace at esl one
katowice 2015.
what could possibly make you tilt more
than all of my standing in ace of the
first
round of the game that seems that seems
unbelievable
few players have become more synonymous
with the tec-9 over the years
than olofmeister with the iconic pistol
in his hands olaf is a
monster on the server and unfortunately
for them nobody
knows that better than na'vi definitely
now we have the information at this
point in time it's going to be guardian
picky of brims
and soos look at that running and
gunning takes down jw and all of meister
tec-9 and armor
it's a really really good combination
but unless they fight him one of the
time oh my god they will pronax
helping out with that kill and guardian
going down it's now a triple kill for
all of mice he's got plenty of help to
do this as well
zeus is very low seized although oh my
god he gets another kill in now clutch
running out seven seconds all of my
looking for the kill five seconds
he goes for his head shot and it's gonna
be the round done
it was the opening pistol round and olaf
was the only one on the server with a
tec-9
but that's all fnatic needed to turn
what probably should have been a round
loss
into a big fat w
coming up next at the number nine spot
is easy with just about the cleanest usp
ace
you're ever likely to see that one's one
of the nicest pistol aces i think i've
ever seen i think that is
one of the best usps aces of all time
how many bullets does it take to kill a
team well obviously the dream is five
and a z did it in eight but honestly
that is pretty
damn good bunch of connector i think
that is our jungle
can't really remember all those smokes
after the new update this is stir smoke
and now oh ac doubles up triples up what
is that
that's criminal hazy's looking unreal
down in ct wants to try and get more
done and oh my goodness easy
[Applause]
just look at those crispy one taps and
if those don't do it for you
then the headshot through the smoke to
close it out probably will
definitely one of the sexiest aces of
all time
for our number eight entry jax puts his
sneaky beaky skills to work
to absolutely terrorize vitality and
they're all his shocks is on the other
side oh dear by the jackson hunter goes
down that's
it that's a disaster jax is on his own
and they know exactly where he is he's
trying to escape trying to reposition
just to make it a little bit tricky but
he's gonna have to get at least two more
kills here before this round is even
close and there's one of them hiding
inside the smoke he might be a genius
he's taken down the suture and now the
pistols out
what a god-like play from jackson he's
still
baiting them out continuing on job what
oh god
that's the ace from jax i've never seen
anything like it
it all starts when the frenchman throws
down a smoke in the middle of sight
and uses the space it creates to
absolute perfection
dancing around it and deleting vitality
players
as he goes that's his own smoke the way
he utilizes this is such a genius
performance
i am stunned that jax just busted this
out
that's gotta be the most perfectly
played round i have ever seen
even in a game as cerebral as
counter-strike
there are times when you just gotta
switch off your brain and push
and for our number seven spot shocks did
just that
but ak-47s they smoke or spawn they
molotov the boosted position as well to
make sure there's no players waiting but
guardians
and shocks it pushed through with the
ump what the hell he's going for four
kills here the usb could be enough
that is absolutely magnificent from
shoxy
and now we've got olofmeister left in a
compromised position
with the i can't believe it let's be
honest
on paper this play doesn't make a lot of
sense
hold w through the smoke and the flames
with the ump right into
three aks and an op shocks should have
been a goner
and yet it's the ump alex of all the
weapons
coming through the smoke we did say the
chance of the mid split there but i
didn't expect it to be cracked
wide open taking the number six spot on
our list is stewie2k
who to absolutely no one's surprise is
willing to push through
anything to get his ace if you want to
talk about a devil in counter strike he
uses flames and an mp9
to get an immediate ace that might be
the fastest ace in history
now it doesn't always work but in the
esl one bella horizonte group stage
stewie showed that playing like an
absolute lunatic can pay off
big time there's been one round in the
last 13 rush now map
right now 14. i should say 4sk or ss and
you're right b rush
absolutely coming in stewie's the only
one in there and he's got an mp9
he's gonna get flashed in he's gonna
just go for it he's just going forward
oh my god stewie
have you ever seen an ace like that
now there's a reason they call stewie
the smoke criminal but i'm thinking
after this play
we might want to change that to molly
criminal
at the halfway point in our list is the
immortal heco who channels shades of the
alamo at sivo season 8
back in 2015. i feel like i'm trapped
i'm trapped inside of a meme right now
in a human reaction
i need a tactical timeout for the
casting desk now hiko is known for
clutching out some of the most
insane rounds in cs go history but this
is on a whole new level the kills start
to trickle in four spots listen let's
see decide it will once again just be
hiko
is he about to pull off the alamo he's
got three from behind quad can he find a
fourth
he gets the fourth he's on for the
eighth and he gets it
trapped in quad with nothing but a tec-9
in his hands and five players looking to
erase him from the server
he goes somehow someway comes out on top
what a god
taking the number four spot on this list
is dupreeh and
his deagle okay dupreeh they're starting
to arrive now they needed that round
desperately
just as it eagles to work with parents
and p250s and dupree
with the ace at esl one katowice 2017
dupree showed how masterfully he handles
one of csgo's most
unwieldy guns and nico gonna go straight
in
with glaive to watch them off dupree to
play at bags could swing back in that
direction because he air isn't going to
be pressure but he doesn't know that
he's also flashed off eagle works though
limited vision limited
weapons doesn't even matter dude
oh the fourth is well how sick is this
round for him and he's looking for the
eighth
the first chase from any one of the
strollers in this tournament and now
we're getting pumped
he stood his ground against faze clan
with nothing but a pistol
in his hands and the heads began to roll
i think sadiq has put it best limited
vision limited weapons
didn't even matter at the number three
spot we have an ace clutch from guardian
circa 2018
that proved once again that he was among
the world's best auburns
the world's best sniper comes alive in
the five
versus one fanatic that is a huge fumble
you cannot afford those mistakes
at iem calavite 2018 faze were getting
bullied by fnatic early on on overpass
in a 1v5 situation round nine looked all
but
over for guardian and the boys but
llatislav
sukka kovach does not go down that easy
opting instead to put on a masterclass
in ace clutches the man who i thought
was gonna go for the contact play player
suddenly the last
alive oh this is a done round guardian
now as
question as to whether he'll save the
awp good flashbang could get a couple
more out of this one
and fanatic are starting to crumble
what's going on
one player has found three kills
guardian looking to ace this one out
this could be one of the best rounds
of the entire tournament so far four
kills picked up it's down the crimped
this was a five versus one map how does
he work back in it's gone toward the
dumpster that means guardian knows
exactly where to load
he's got all five
there he is
[Applause]
at the runner-up spot on this list we
have the wolf of wall street himself
chris j that's gonna be one of the
sickest plays of the tournament maybe
even of the year
chris j shuts everything down look at
this this is counter-strike perfection
right now
up 14-8 on the last map of the grand
finals of esl one new york 2018
mousesports were about to run away with
the tournament
but victory is just so much sweeter if
you win
in style so chris j decided to put
liquid out of their misery
and pick up some serious style points
with a stunning
rotate back through the officer that
gives the leaves position wants to try
and hold cat
excuse me catwalk from connector wants
to try and hold off the rotation oscar's
gone chris isn't up still in the picture
oh still very much in the round oh chris
he's found three it's down to it
on two chris can he close this with an
axe
oh my god chris the wolf of wall street
gets an ace
and it's championship point mouse sports
[Applause]
taking the top spot on our list is
csgo's
play of the decade yeah it's the happy
deagle ace i think i just broke my chair
i might need a new one
yep i think i actually did just break my
chair hold on let me get into it there's
actually a lot to say about this play i
mean was it skill
was it luck was it a lot of both either
way
fans decided that it was so incredible
they voted for it as csgo's play of the
decade
and look we're not about to argue we'll
just let the play
speak for itself the tsm they're scared
about this
they're re they aren't rushing this time
around they're taking their sweet time
hoping
to catch somebody peak on envy's side
and well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with juan dig
oh and another one
[Applause]
debris is like sweating bullets he's
gonna get the quad killing the ice
what is this
i think i just broke my chair i might
need a new one yep i think i actually
did just break my chair hold on let me
get into it
a worthy sacrifice a chair for a round
that's gonna go down in history without
a doubt here
okay guys before you click off this
video i need you to do one thing for me
and that is get the score esports ace
that means
one tap the subscribe button spray down
the comments section
nade stack that like button go to our
instagram page and
up flick that follow button and most
crucially
go to twitch.tv slash the score esports
and knife that follow button
all right guys for this post credits
scene for this end board whatever you
want to call it
i wanted to deliver a message of
self-care from me
to you i really want to say take some
time
for yourself take a break go outside
get a hobby restart rekindle
or strengthen some relationships in your
life and make sure that there are things
that you care about in life
that don't always begin and end at your
workstation
take care of yourselves